in my opinion the crisis was primarily
created by government policies
specifically the Federal Reserve printed
too much money under Greenspan where we
had negative real interest rates for two
years and then Bernanke inverted you
interest rates and which created a
terrible pressure on brain bank margins
we couldn't have had a bubble in the
economy if the Fed hadn't printed too
much money it ended up in the housing
market because of Freddie Mac and Fannie
Mae these two giant government-sponsored
enterprises so it wasn't really the
regulatory structure that that created
the problems it was government policy
from the Fed in the end through Freddie
Mac and Fannie Mae and what his irony is
the perception that the banking industry
was deregulated in fact the regulatory
environment during the bubble was the
worst in my career it was just miss
regulation there's a huge amount of
focus on soybeans I see a huge amount of
focus on the Patriot Act and and no
focus really on traditional risk
management so they may they contributed
to the crisis more in an indirect way
but the real cause of the misallocations
in the economic system came from the
Federal Reserve and Freddie Mac and
Fannie Mae
I was very opposed to the tarp program
in fact I wrote Congress and tried very
hard to keep carp from happening
unfortunately however once tarp and was
approved by Congress there was
significant regulatory pressure placed
on all the large financial institutions
to participate in tarp particularly on
all the hundred billion dollar and over
banks the pressure was based on Bernanke
study the Great Depression where
Roosevelt tried to bail out individual
companies and the market reacted when he
did that at the time that talk was
instituted there were three large
financial institutions that were under
stress but Bernanke didn't want to bail
those three out because it be obvious he
was helping helping them so he use
regulatory I mean intense regulatory
pressure to encourage all the 100
billion dollar and over institutions to
participate tarp was really a negative
for the healthy financial institutions
we didn't need the capital and we had to
pay very high interest rate they got
warrants and so it was really a subsidy
for the unhealthy institutions at the
expense of the healthy institutions BB&T
was one of the first banks to pay back
tarp we paid it back as quickly as we
possibly could
all the large financial institutions 100
billion dollar-plus institutions were
basically strongly encouraged
effectively forced to participate in
tarp because the Federal Reserve didn't
want the market to know the specific
institutions that were being bailed out
and by encouraging everybody including
the strong Institute institutions to
participate they obscured the fact that
certain institutions from being saved if
you didn't need the capital the fact
that you had to pay a very high interest
rate and give warrants to the government
was very expensive in our case that was
several hundred million dollars probably
and it turned out when they did the
stress test we didn't we really didn't
need the capital anyway so I thought it
was a redistribution from the healthy
institutions to the unhealthy
institutions and not good government
policy although they had created such a
panic they may have needed to do
something but I don't think tarp was the
answer
I think the long-term consequences are
very negative and the classic example is
GMAC GMAC is the automobile finance arm
of General Motors GMAC contributed a lot
to the problem we have in the automobile
business in order to sell automobiles a
number of years ago they invented the
100% car loan payable over seven years
and what that meant is most people owe
more on their car than it was worth
after three or four years so they can't
go buy a new car and now of course you
may see got a lot of cars back and and
had huge losses in that regard and now
the government keeps pouring money into
GMAC keeping them in business under the
theory that there's no financing for
automobiles which is not true people
like us are in the car business we just
don't want aren't going to do the dumb
stuff that GMAC is doing and you can't
miss allocate capital invest in things
that shouldn't be done and raise your
standard of living in the long term and
and that's what government policy is
doing so poorly what institutions need
to fail and then that council gets
reallocated to better run institutions
that's the way Marcos work you have to
have a downside and and I do think that
the healthy institutions have definitely
been hurt hurt badly by keeping the
unhealthy institutions in business
because these unhealthy competitors are
continuing to do things that drive down
margins of profitability for the healthy
institutions you could see healthy
institutions in trouble because of
keeping unhealthy in business